what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can't decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
so with injustice 2 coming out in the
really in next few days or so to be out
of the think we're probably around three
or four days away which is really really
exciting but what I want to do here is
is be a little bit dangerous I want to
go ahead and be a little risky here and
what I want to do is I want to cover the
origin of a lot of the new characters
who are going to be an injustice but
here's the reason why so we're going to
be a little bit dangerous when injustice
one we didn't really get the origin
story of characters per se I mean we had
things like Nightwing which just turned
out to be Damian Wayne but we didn't
know until he read the injustice comic
how it was that we got from Damian
Wayne's being Robin to becoming
Nightwing ah that was one of the great
little expositions that we got but even
then we really didn't get the origin
story for a lot of those characters now
a lot of that was because of the fact
that injustice largely centered on the
Justice League and it was really
Superman just falling down to becoming
an evil guy and so for the most part
because of the legacy of the characters
involved you know Green Lantern Hal
Jordan you know Wonder Woman Superman
Batman and so on those origin stories
are for the most part timeless and most
everybody knows what they are and so it
wasn't really necessary for DC to give
us those origins but if injustice to if
that comic follows the trend of
injustice 1 then dark side will just
suddenly be there you know Brainiac will
just be there we may or may not get
those origin stories and so what I
wanted to do was grab this origin from
DC Comics and throw it in so it may be
that when the game comes out this
changes it maybe this is the origin they
go with they may never even confirm this
is the origin but at the very least
it'll give you a general idea of what to
expect and what the motivations are
behind the character of Brainiac so the
most recent origin for his character
came out of a one-shot of I think it was
Superman 23.2 as part of the new 52 now
keep in mind when DC rebooted in 2011
the idea was to basically just kind of
restart everything from scratch the only
exceptions being Green Lantern Hal
Jordan and Batman but with regards to
the Superman mythos new origin stories
were given for a lot of characters
Darkseid Brainiac so on and so forth and
so because of that what this does is it
basically shows us what Brainiac is all
about now initially this picks up in
three locations
the first is Planet jezzer I think it's
how you pronounce it the second is a
planet Briah and the third is planet
Noma and these are all three different
individuals who have some similarity and
physical appearance to Brainiac him
and the reason why is because on the
planet Noma a person is basically being
being taken is a person named Victoria
vice right now the reason why why
Victoria Viceroy is has been taken here
will be explained by the time we get by
the time we get to the end of the story
but what ends up happening is that this
sort of field commander I guess or this
aspect of rainy act basically begins
telling her everything that's going on
why it is that they're here and what it
does is it basically wins back to the
early days of a guy by the name of real
dodge now real Doc's was basically
displayed here as a genius as a
scientist of source but something that I
want you to notice is that there are a
lot of similarities between what goes on
with regards to this story and what goes
on with the origin of Superman
they're not identical and they're not
designed to be but there are a lot of
similarities now initially all we really
have is world ox just kind of
experimenting on someone and we assume
there's just a random individual some
person he's taken somewhere along the
lines but when his wife enters the room
we end up finding out that vril dox is
experimenting on his son now we don't
really know exactly what his motivations
are at the moment all we know is that
he's basically going through and
performing some kind of experiment on
him now the similarities between
brainiacs and Superman only come in so
far that is a mother it's a father and
it's a son I mean you know we'll get
into a few more the similarities later
on but that's one of the things that I
wanted to sort of point out is because
with Superman having been the template
or the standard behind all modern-day
superheroes and even some super villains
his origin story is visit affinity
origin story in terms of just timeless
stories and so because of that a lot of
the origins that came later on down the
line we're in some form of fashion
modeled after him that is to say you
know a person an individual or being
that loses those around him people that
have to make sacrifices different things
like that but of course the response of
real daksha's wife is one of absolute
disgust similarly because of the fact
that he's experimenting on their child
now this is when we started getting a
few more similarities in terms of real
docs basically speaking to the committee
of the planet that they're on you know
yad yad Cola laughing is how you
pronounce it but what he basically says
is that through his own studies through
his own research he's basically
discovered something called the fifth
dimension now we as readers of DC Comics
know the fifth dimension is the home of
like mr. Mixel pedelec and bat-mite
individuals who have you know technology
that's so
dream that it might as well be magic and
so because of that the abilities of
individuals inside the fifth dimension
allow them to effectively work reality
in a three-dimensional space and so what
this means is that with these various
wars and conflicts taking place inside
the fifth dimension some individuals or
some groups of one of which is referred
to as the multitude has basically
engineered its escape now the way the
multitude is depicted here in this story
is that they are in fact what amounts to
a force of nature I mean they're like
well really they kind of described as
locusts and in a lot of ways they are
but where locusts will show up and
they'll eat you know plant life and
everything's like that crops and so on
and so forth the multitude will just
raise worlds and then destroy them and
so they basically wipe out everything
that they come across and so what what
was going on here with regards to brill
docks experimenting on his son and she
was basically saying hey look you know
this group is coming towards us this
group is coming to our planet the reason
why i was experimenting on my son was to
basically find a way to effectively
enhance our people to move us in a
direction so that when this group
arrives here we can find a way to fight
them off now again this is very you know
end of times apocalyptic very similar to
the Superman mythos which is to say
jor-el basically discovery the impending
destruction of Krypton trying to find a
way to save it the council that was
willing over Krypton at the time refused
to hear him out and it resulted in the
planets destruction with Superman being
sent away as its sole survivor and so
because of this the origin story of a
Brainiac is very similar in the sense
that this committee refuses to hear him
out they consider him to be crazy
because of that he's basically exiled
and he is sent away now at this point
this is when DC begins to get into just
how intense and how intelligent Brainiac
is what we end up finding out here is
that brill docks was basically the guy
who engineered the computer systems of
his home planet and so while he was
basically sent away because he had
engineered the computer system designed
to keep him captive the committee that
had him arrested basically threw him in
a Cell and then gave him the key and so
because of this brill docks basically
uses his own abilities that is to say
basically the things that he had
programmed into the software to allow
him to seize control at any point in
time and basically takes control of this
program and then re Institute's his own
computo program which is basically just
was all an interface the ability for him
to talk to the computer someone and so
forth but wonders of happening if you
begins the process
manipulating his own physical structure
now in terms of the steps he takes to do
this DC does not really give us an
in-depth explanation in a lot of ways
brainiac is symbolic because of how he
looks but more so than that it's the
things that he does that make him so
dangerous the fact that he's so
intelligent the fact he's so cold the
fact that he's so calculating that's
what makes him so interesting he's like
a far more extreme version of Lex Luthor
and so because of this the Brainiac
basically returns back to his world and
says hey look I'm here to save you guys
I'm here to save all of you because this
world is going to be destroyed now
notice that where he had previously
pleaded to the committee who was there
now he's making demands and it raises
some pretty interesting points here
because it's like if he warned them that
their destruction was imminent and they
refused to listen then it begs the
question well what road would you take
would you simply lead them to their fate
would you say hey look I tried to warn
you didn't want to listen now you have
to deal with the consequences welcome to
the world of what happens when you fail
to heed advice that's going to benefit
you or he simply just does what he's
doing now and whisks some of them away
but what this does is it sets him down
the path of the most notable act that
Brainiac consistently commits one of the
things that Brainiac is most known for
is the fact that he basically captures
and bottle cities that's his thing now
the fact that he does that has brought
him to earth on a multitude of occasions
in an attempt to basically whisk things
away and that was the basis behind the
whole convergence event but the idea
here is that the first city that he I
guess the first place that he basically
takes is the city in which his wife and
his son exist now this is him not doing
it because he's altruistic this is him
just doing it as a matter of
practicality and that's what he ends up
doing for you just travels from one
location to the next basically showing
up on planets that are next on the list
of planets that will be destroyed by the
multitude stealing one of their cities
and then taking them away now because of
this of course the home planet of real
dogs is basically obliterated in its
entirety and it's kind of ironic because
there's only in the moment of complete
and total destruction though the people
who banished him realized he was right
it's a bit of irony of sorts but even
then he basically goes back about
creating multiple aspects of himself and
that's really what's established here
that there is the prime Brainiac and
then there's the other versions that
people most commonly see and it was
really the most intelligent way of doing
things so the reason why is because if
you were to go on a quest to basically
preserve some form of all the different
worlds
that will eventually be destroyed by the
multitude then it would take too long he
would basically fall behind because a
multitude moves so incredibly fast but
by making different aspects of himself
he's able to basically preserve one
portion of these different worlds now
here's the kicker to this is that with
Brainiac capturing these different you
know covering different cities or
capturing a city on a world the idea
here is he's basically just saying I'm
going to preserve a part of this world
because their destruction is not there
they're you know the end is imminent and
so because this dimension he comes
across Krypton now the funny thing about
this is that Krypton at this point in
time is not on the verge of complete and
total destruction and in fact jor-el is
still basically studying the planet and
will eventually come to the realization
that is going to be obliterated in its
entirety but during this particular
point in time when Brainiac first visits
Brainiac actually goes there and steals
this city of Kandor and so that's
whether that's were the you know the
really famous name the bottle city of
Kandor that you've probably heard of
before that's where that comes from
Brainiac basically takes that is one of
the cities because in his mind Krypton
is going to be yet another world that's
destroyed by the multitude the kicker is
that jor-el actually finds a way to fend
off against the multitude now as far as
I'm aware we're not given the story on
how that happens ah at least we have I
haven't been able to find it but the
fact that jor-el was able to help fight
off the multitude and preserve Krypton
let Brainiac to return back to back to
Krypton itself in order to find out what
it was that jor-el did so that Brainiac
could basically copy whatever it was you
know whatever that actual was duplicated
and then use that to effectively fight
off and destroy the multitude within the
DC universe the problem is that by the
time Brainiac got back Krypton had been
destroyed and Superman was on his way to
earth and so because of this what it
does is it circles back around to this
particular I guess this whole thing with
Victoria Viceroy and what happens is the
prime Brainiac shows up when she begins
making declarations of his you know this
aspect of himself where she says look
you know show me you know tell you what
it is that he's doing what's he actually
after and what Brainiac says is that it
is true he's not being altruistic he's
not preserving these different cities
because it's the right thing to do he's
preserving these cities because for him
if he cannot keep the planet if he can't
save the planet that he's going to
destroy before the multitude can not
only that when he gets to the planet
when he gets to a world that's going to
be destroyed by
a multitude if you cannot find anyone
who can basically duplicate what it was
jor-el did and being successful in
destroying the multitude then Brainiac
will destroy that planet first and so
that's one of the one of the crazy
things he's on a very dark path you know
it does this planet have the ability to
destroy the multitude if they don't
steal a city blow up the planet and
that's really where he's at right now
that's pretty much all he does is travel
to space ways doing exactly that so what
is it happening here is that this
ultimately results in the fact that
Brainiac realizes Victoria Viceroy does
not have the ability to preserve you
know the planet Noma and fight off the
multitude and so of course he basically
leaves her to her fate and annihilates
the planet but what this does is this
segues into the new 52 Superman going
forward into a new story arc so again we
can kind of wrap it up here and this is
really where like deep origin of
Brainiac really begins to come to a
close but if you guys want to see more
things like this because I think it's
kind of cool to delve into these origins
stories for characters we'll be seeing
in injustice too even if the origins
won't necessarily be 100% accurate when
the game comes out they might make a few
changes here and there something like
that but if you guys are interested in
seeing more things like this and let me
know and we'll keep them coming out
every Friday until we finish them and
then you know the first story arc of
injustice queue wraps up and then we go
ahead and cover that but if you guys are
new here to college explain make sure
you guys have the sub button to become
part of the Rob port if you guys enjoyed
this video make sure you drop a like and
yeah I will catch you later peace
[Music]